leftists target chick-fil-a again more
fallout from the Trump Kim summit and
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan sets an
immigration vote I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
plenty to get to today if you missed it
last night we had a great new episode of
daily wire backstage with me and Andrew
Clavin and Michael Mills and Jeremy
boring it was a lot of fun you should go
check that out on YouTube you can check
it out as well on iTunes or SoundCloud
if you subscribe I believe it came out
in your feed this morning and we have a
lot to get to today first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over $1 shave
club so if you have a shower or brush
your teeth or try to make your hair look
presentable like you're a human being
you need Dollar Shave Club I know your
bathroom is just filled with all sorts
of garbage that is just all over the
place well clean all that crap out and
instead get all the great stuff from
Dollar Shave Club so they deliver
everything you need to look feel and
smell your best it's shampoo conditioner
body wash toothpaste hair gel even a
wipe that leaves your butt feeling
tingly clean I'm a big fan of their
common body cleanser seriously the other
night my wife said why do you smell so
good and she knew it was not the usual
odor of been and instead it was the
calming body cleanser the amber and
lavender delight that was the calming
body cleanser
sometimes when I need to calm down I
just put on that calming body cleanser
I'm ready that really is actually pretty
spectacular all of Dollar Shave club's
products are made with top-shelf
ingredients that won't break your budget
and you will feel the difference plus
shipping is included with your
membership so here's the best way to try
all of their products for just five
bucks you can get their daily essentials
starter set it comes with body cleanser
one wipe Charlies the amazing butt wipes
the world-famous shea butter and their
best razor the six blade executive you
can keep the blades coming for a few
bucks more per month add in shampoo
toothpaste or anything else you need for
the bathroom check it all out at
dollarshaveclub.com slash pen that is
dollarshaveclub.com slash been so in a
little while we're going to get to
president Trump in the fallout from the
North Korean summit President Trump has
been tweeting some things which are in
my opinion not the smartest but with
that said obviously this big public
relations coup for the president the
president had himself a hell of a day in
the last couple of days he had he had a
hell of a 48 hours going to Singapore
and walking around with Kim and then
getting all sorts of good media coverage
for it his approval ratings are going to
rise because of it it's a very popular
movie even those of us who are skeptical
like me are so obviously hopeful that
President Trump it ends up being right
and this wasn't a stop to Kim for a
photo-op and it actually ends up curbing
Kim's nuclear ambitions and you know
what why don't we just jump right into
this the president Trump this morning he
tweets out quote just landed a long trip
but everybody can now feel so much safer
than the day I took office there's no
longer a nuclear threat from North Korea
mean with
Kim jong-un was an interesting and very
positive experience North Korea has
great potential for the future and
listen I think that if North Korea
decides to integrate into the family of
Nations and liberalize and get rid of
the nuclear weapons there is a great
potential for the future for president
Trump to say preemptively there's no
longer a nuclear threat from North
Korea's obviously untrue there's not a
single North Korean weapon that has been
disarmed at this point they have not
destroyed any of their nuclear capacity
and this sort of preliminary
triumphalism I objected into it to it
yesterday because I think that it boxes
president trumpet I think President
Trump wants to actually get something
good out of North Korea it is trust but
verify but you actually have to verify
and you can't trust that he's disarming
when he hasn't disarmed he hasn't even
said a timetable for disarming the North
Korean headlines that were the one
they're putting out in North Korea
suggests that Kim is telling his own
people that the United States and North
Korea have agreed to joint disarmament
what that technically means is that Kim
jong-un is claiming to his own people
the United States is going to disarm
nuclear Lee alongside North Korea which
of course is totally insane and never
going to happen
Trump also tweeted before taking off as
people were assuming that we were going
to war with North Korea President Obama
said that North Korea was our biggest
and most dangerous problem no longer
sleep well tonight
well again the sort of preliminary
triumphalism I think is actually not
useful and is pretty counterproductive
because here's the thing what President
Trump did is he basically signs in
advance against or royalties so when
you're in the book industry right when
you write a book then publishers
typically give you in advance and the
advance is supposed to incentivize you
to write the book and then you write the
book and then you get royalties on the
back ends but you don't immediately get
the royalties instead what happens is
that you have to pay off your advance so
if they advance you $20,000 for in
advance you have to make $20,000 worth
of royalties and those go back to the
publisher and then you make whatever
royalties are on top of that well in
negotiations what President Trump
effectively just did is he gave Kim
jong-eun in advance against royalties he
said listen I'm gonna give you
preemptively preliminary a lot of
credibility on the world stage I'm gonna
let you stand up here with me I'm gonna
give you the honor of shaking my hand
I'm going to allow you to fly your flag
alongside the flag of the United States
I'm gonna grant you tremendous
international legitimacy which does have
a practical impact it means that a bunch
of countries located around North Korea
are not going to isolate North Korea
nearly as intensely as they were before
instead it looks like they're going to
try and move for a normalization of
relations with North Korea all of that
is Priya
to give by the presidents of the United
States now as I said yesterday maybe
this ends up being a triumph the way it
ends up being a triumph is if kim
jeong-hoon actually doesn't want to come
to the table and not just come to the
table but offered tea nuclearization in
a real way if it turns out the president
Trump gave an advance against royalties
and then Kim jong-un doesn't earn out
right Kim Jong Un's book doesn't sell
Kim Jong Un's doesn't actually give
President Trump what he wants in return
then president Trump got bamboozled and
the real question is going to be is
president Trump willing to flip his
president Trump because of the the mark
of a good negotiation here if you're
gonna give an advance against royalties
is he claw that back right if Kim Jong
Un's lying if he's not telling the truth
then Trump claws it back now I have very
little doubt that if President Trump is
humiliated by Kim jong-un publicly that
he will go after Kim jong-un personally
he has done that before with all the
little rocket man talk which by the way
I kind of liked right man I talked about
it at the time and I said that was kind
of hilarious and worthwhile even you
know it is the president willing to flip
on on kim jong hoon now we know that
president obama was not willing to flip
on people who screwed him and talked so
when it came to iran president obama was
so invested in the idea that he'd gotten
a great deal then when it was very clear
that Iran was using all of the money
that they had now gotten for terrorism
and long-range missile development Obama
kept proclaiming that Iran had been
moderated that something magical had
been done in Iran he became the PR
agency for Iran well what you don't want
from the Trump administration is for
them to become the PR agency for North
Korea because they're so invested in the
possibility of a deal that they start
pretending that a deal exists when a
deal does not exist that's why I don't
think that it is worthwhile for
president Trump to be going out there
and preemptively saying that North Korea
is no longer a threat or a problem that
we've solved everything
that's not verification right that's
just trust you need trust but verify
yeah President Reagan people are
comparing Trump to Reagan because Trump
met with Kim jong-un and Reagan met with
Mikhail Gorbachev but Reagan never came
away from a meeting with Malcolm Mikhail
Gorbachev and said listen the USSR is no
longer a threat
they've been disarmed everybody can
sleep easy in their bed tonight Reagan
never said that what he said is the
negotiations are progressing we're
working on something we're going to try
and get them where we need to go it's
moving in the right direction
all of that I think would be more useful
for the president than for the president
to go out there and start preliminarily
declaring victory he also said we save a
fortune by not doing war games as long
as we are negotiating in good faith with
boat which both sides are again it's not
up to the president to determine whether
than whether the North Koreans
are negotiating in good faith we don't
know that yet we just don't know that
yet and to assume that they are
negotiating in good faith is I think a
fool's errand we actually have to assume
they're negotiating in bad faith until
they prove it to us right this should be
show me and it's time for the Kim family
to show the United States to show
President Trump that they really mean
what it is they are saying and this is
not me being critical of President Trump
for the sake of being critical of
President Trump I spent the last several
weeks praising President Trump on issues
ranging from the Jerusalem move to some
of his domestic policies with regard to
regulation go back and listen to the
show I've been doing it for weeks right
but the fact is that when President
Trump is putting himself in a bad
position these are the negotiations he's
putting himself in a bad position visa
vie negotiations and he's putting the
United States in a bad position visa vie
negotiations now is it possible of all
this works yes but it's a high risk high
gamble right I mean this is a high-risk
gamble the president is making right now
it's high-risk high-reward maybe he goes
out there he shakes hands he takes it on
himself he makes it look as though he's
legitimizing him and then it turns out
that Kim is Mikhail Gorbachev and
something great comes out of this maybe
that's what happens here but I'm gonna
wait for the great thing to come out of
it before I start preliminarily praising
and when I see the wild praise that's
happening on TV or the wild rips that
are happening on it's the end of the
world this is obviously stupid when I
see both of those things happening it
suggests to me that people are jumping
to their partisan hackery
that people are jumping to I want this
to be good I want this to be good for
president Trump I like president Trump I
trust President Trump therefore I'm not
gonna trust but verify about president
Trump I'm just going to trust President
Trump well I don't trust any president
okay I trust President Trump on policy
much more than I trusted President Obama
obviously but in the end everything has
to be verified and the deal has to be
verified so president Trump tweets out
that we are losing by that we save a
fortune by not doing war games as long
as we are negotiating in good faith
number one you shouldn't be using the
term war games war games is a North
Korean propaganda term for what it is
the United States does with South Korea
those are military exercises and
military naval exercises that we do with
South Korea for preparedness for our
troops or I've talked to members of the
military yesterday who talked about what
it is that we do in South Korea those
war games supposedly are also directed
toward China right they're directed for
training up a group of folks who can
work in concert with American troops if
God forbid some sort of military
conflict breaks out on the peninsula
look we all want the same thing here we
all want North Korea to disarm the
question is whether you think that
president Trump's original approach
right the harsh approach
North Korea was more likely to bear
fruit or if you think that President
Trump has to really give kim jeong runa
bear hug in order to accomplish this i
think that neither is particularly
necessary I think that I would rather
have president from wielding a big stick
and letting his lower level negotiators
going to negotiate a deal rather than
preemptively granting Kim jong-un all
this sort of international credibility
and legitimacy and taking our allies in
the region and making them more friendly
to kim jeong-hoon again high-risk
high-reward
mm if it pays off it's great if it
doesn't then it's not gonna be all that
great and we're not gonna know that for
at least several months probably so
president Trump didn't stop there let me
tweet it out so funny to watch the fake
news especially NBC and CNN they're
fighting hard to downplay the deal of
North Korea 500 days ago they would have
begged for the deal looked like war
would break out our country's biggest
enemy is the fake moon so easily
promulgated by fools now you know
look III think when President Trump rips
into the fake news I think sometimes
that's absolutely justified I think that
it is absolutely justified for the
president to point out that a year ago
everybody was deeply worried that North
Korea is going to nuke us into
obliteration right we were going to get
into a nuclear exchange with North Korea
just a few months ago the media were
proclaiming that Trump was was somehow
going to gin up a nuclear war on the
Korean Peninsula and now it's Trump
surrendering well which is it guys I
mean either you either you like kind of
more muscular Trump or you like
negotiating Trump but you got to pick
one you can't do this routine where
Trump is either going to bring about
world peace or he's gonna bring about
nuclear war this this inconsistency from
media really is quite calling so I
understand why President Trump is upset
with that said you know when the
president says our country's biggest
enemy is the fake news and then at the
same time like really within a couple of
hours he's tweeting out that North Korea
is no longer our biggest and most
dangerous problem instead they have
great potential for the future and
there's no longer a nuclear threat can
the North Koreans that that is still an
evil regime okay as much as I dislike a
lot of members of the mainstream media
as much they think that they are lying
on a frequent basis or at least biasing
their coverage on a frequent basis I'm
not gonna pretend that I think of the
the anchors at CNN in the same way I
think of kim jeong-hoon
kara country's greatest enemy are not
the fake news our country's biggest
enemy our places like North Korea still
at least until they prove that they are
not our enemy and they have not come
close to proving that as of yet so mr.
president take a page from the Reagan
playbook trust but verify
trust but verify and in the case of kim
jeong-hoon haven't even trust but verify
nothing has been put on paper yet in the
case of kim jong hoon i would distrust
and verify and the verification
protocols should be even stronger for
kim jong than they normally would be i
have a little bit more on this first i
want to say thanks to our sponsors over
at Skillshare so Skillshare is an online
learning platform with over 20,000
classes in business design technology
and more you can take classes in social
media marketing illustration data
science mobile photography creative
writing you name it they've got it skill
skill show is great because if you
listen to the show I know you love
information I know that you love
learning I know it's something that you
are just really enthusiastic about
that's why we recommend books on the
program every day well when you need to
learn a skill you shouldn't be going to
YouTube and watching some doofus do
something for five minutes and now
you're an expert on marketing it's not
the way that works should be talking
with an expert you should be learning
from an expert and that's where skill
share comes in these are 45-minute
classes with experts in their various
fields I've taken classes in social
media marketing and SEO I took one in
watercolours from Skillshare they really
aren't terrific folks in the office you
said it's a great way to make your
resume deeper and broader it's a great
way to ensure that you have an updated
skillset at all times and right now you
can join the millions of listeners
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer for my listeners
get two months of Skillshare for just 99
cents right now skill show is offering
ben shapiro show listeners two months of
an unlimited access to over 20,000
classes for just 99 cents again
Skillshare comm slash capiro that skill
shared calm / prepare to start your two
months for free right now or for just 99
cents right now that skill shared calm /
appear oh go check it out you really
will enjoy it and I'm gonna use that /
bet and that / capiro it lets them know
that we sent you as well okay so you
know again should we be optimistic about
what President Trump is doing in with
North Korea sure sure I think optimism
is warranted
I think everybody should be optimistic
and hopeful the president needs to be
the strong leader he has been on foreign
policy I've been very critical of the
president when I think he's wrong I
think that there's risk the president is
wrong here and I think the president
needs to show the same sort of strength
and fortitude as he did when it came to
the Iran deal that he is with the with
the North Koreans you'll remember he
rejected the Iran deal
he said the Iran deal is no longer good
because we cannot trust the Iranians and
I was after we had signed a deal he said
we cannot trust them that was Obama's
deal so he wasn't tied to it what I'm
afraid of is the president Trump is
going to make a deal with the North
Koreans that isn't that great and then
he's going to feel
to that deal because he made the deal in
the first place I hope that's not the
case and I think his advisors I hope
will advise him that that should not be
the case yeah mr. president
by all means extend the warm hands in
North Korea if you think that that's
going to succeed but on the other hand
it's a velvet glove and inside there
must be an iron fist and if the iron
fist is gone already then we've just
handed Kim jong-un a victory there's
either gonna be a trumpian triumph or
it's going to be a kim coup and
president Trump gets to decide how that
goes
remember this is not a negotiation
between equals the United States the
most powerful country in the history of
the world by a factor of 10 there is no
reason that the United States should
have to stoop down to Kim Jong Un's
level in order to get him to do anything
and the fact is that President Trump is
already granting some sort of
concessions to the Chinese so listen
maybe I'm totally wrong here maybe the
president has in his back pocket a big
win from Kim if so then I look forward
to seeing that big win so far all I've
seen is in advance on royalties from the
president to kim jeong-hoon I don't see
that as a victory for the United States
unless there is a back end to this deal
if it turns out the president advanced a
bunch of trust to Kim and can actually
wants to do something everything will be
fine if not then the president made a
big mistake and got bamboo by mam
boozled by Kim and I'm not gonna
preemptively declare one way or another
as so many people seem to want me to and
so many people seem to be angry that I
am NOT I'm not preliminary celebration
about negotiations is not my favorite
thing I just don't think negotiations
are worth celebrating preliminary ly
it's the outcome of negotiations that
ends up mattering in the long run now
with all of that said this is a very
popular move the polls show that this
may be the most popular initiative that
Trump has ever undertaken there's a new
poll out right now about Trump and Kim
and it shows that voters are somewhat
skeptical that Trump is going to
convince Kim to give up his nukes but
most Americans in South Koreans do in
fact back the summit nearly half of
voters are confident Trump can handle
threats posed by North Korea
but significantly fewer believe he'll be
successful convincing them to get rid of
their nuclear program with that said the
summit itself is very popular because
people feel like something has to break
the impasse I think the American people
are basically correct about all of this
okay well meanwhile the left is
struggling to come up with a message to
run on in 2018 and 2020 and the radicals
on the Left continue to drive the
conversation so there's a big conference
that's supposed to happen in the next
couple of days it's burning Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren I believe cory booker
Shawn
all the perspectives 2020 Democratic
nominees and they keep saying they have
great ideas and I'm waiting to hear
their ideas because I don't really see
their great ideas instead where I see is
that this party which proclaims that it
is mainstream is constantly being driven
to the far left by its base I think
what's happening right now in American
politics is a severe polarization that
is leading to reactionary politics on
both sides of the aisle it is most
obvious not on the right where people
are talking about it a lot it is most
obvious on the left the latest iteration
of this is the newfound campaign against
chick-fil-a so you may have seen over
the last few days that the left has
started campaigning again against
chick-fil-a because it is Gay Pride
Month and that means that we have to
stop homophobic chicken stop it stop
eating your homophobic chicken
sandwiches those chicken sandwiches you
know that those chicken sandwiches have
engraved upon them they've branded upon
them all the grills of chick-fil-a have
Leviticus 18:22 branded upon them so you
have to make sure that you do not come
anywhere close to those homophobic
chicken sandwiches the latest comes from
Noah Mickelson over at Huffington Post
he writes a long piece called if you
really love LGBTQ people you can't just
keep eating chick-fil-a because
apparently that turns you into some sort
of papist or something so here's what
Mickelson writes he says my family
didn't have much money so eating out was
a rare treat but when the trip included
waffle fries and ingenious food so alien
to southern Wisconsin in the early 80s
they seem like a small salty miracle to
my tiny still soft mind it was almost
too much for me to take still as
delicious as the Georgia based companies
fried foods were they weren't my only
weakness as a kid when I wasn't
fantasizing about grease I was spending
my young swishy days doing a really
bleep e job of hiding my insatiable
hunger for other boys so what does that
have to do with the chicken
exactly so Mickelson says you can
imagine how upsetting it was for me when
chick-fil-a's president dan Kathy
proudly came out as a homophobe in 2012
by claiming quote we are inviting God's
judgment on our nation when we shake our
fist at him and say we know better than
you as to what constitutes a marriage
and I pray God's mercy on our generation
that has such a prideful arrogant
attitude to think that we have the
audacity to define what marriage is
about that is not a homophobic statement
by Dan Kathy it's not okay homophobia is
the idea that gay people should be put
in jail or that homosexuality should be
punishable by law or that you are afraid
of gay people but the idea that you
think that homosexual sex is a sin or
that same-sex marriage is in a bomba
nation in terms of sort of the biblical
definition
marriage has pretty mainstream religious
view I have many many gay friends right
I am in favor of the government getting
out of the business of marriage
altogether as a religious person I also
believe that homosexual sex is a sin
because I am in fact a religious Jew
right and this is just part of the
religious Jewish tradition that has
nothing to do with quote-unquote
homophobia anyway because Dan cathy has
these yous now we have to not eat
chicken sandwiches from chick-fil-a now
has chick-fil-a ever told gay people
they can't eat a chick-fil-a no has
chick-fil-a ever fired an employee for
being gay no has does chick-fil-a cover
the benefits of gay employees yes does
chick-fil-a actually provide food to the
victims or the Atlanta of the Orlando
shooting and at a gay nightclub you bet
but apparently because Dan Cathy doesn't
agree with Noah Mickelson it is time for
the entire LGBT community to boycott the
entire company of chick-fil-a now here
is why this is so stupid and so
problematic for the country when you
have entire groups of people boycotting
companies on the basis of the political
perspective of the leader of that
company not based on the activity of the
company right even the even boycott
based on the activity of the company
that I think is fair but boycotting
based on the views of the company's
owner or based on the fact that the
company donates its profits to Christian
groups who have particular view points
on sexual orientation I don't see how
that's good for the country it is not it
means that you are now going to be
obligated to vet the political viewpoint
of everybody you do business with and
then we are going to break off into
these hive minded little cliques of
people who only do business with hang
out with and have conversations with
people with whom we fully agree and we
try to bankrupt everyone else that makes
for a pretty terrible First Amendment
environment in the United States now
this isn't an implication of the First
Amendment itself as in government this
is in government regulation of
chick-fil-a but there's such a thing as
a sort of a free speech attitude and the
free speech attitude in the United
States is going by the wayside as we
call for companies the members of
companies to change their own particular
political viewpoint not their action
their political viewpoint expressed by
them in order so that they can earn our
business it's really really negative and
that's not the only extreme viewpoint
that's now being pushed by the left and
the left is also now pushing extreme
viewpoints with regard to masculinity so
the latest iteration of this comes
courtesy of Sarah rich over at the
Atlantic so Sarah rich has a long piece
over the Atlantic called today's
masculinity is stifling and let me just
point
today's masculinity is less stifling
than at any time in the recent past
because the fact is that today's
masculinity has almost nothing to do
with masculinity masculinity used to be
tied to the idea of obligation to
protect now and I teach my son to be a
gentleman what I'm going to teach him is
that it is necessary to protect those
who are weaker than you are you know if
you ever seen the movie American sniper
there's a long monologue where the main
character talks about how basically
people are either sheep wolves or
sheepdogs either is going to be
aggressors or they are going to be
followers or they're going to be
sheepdogs protecting the sheep against
the wolves it is the job of men to be
sheepdogs essentially that is what being
a gentleman is it's upholding a moral
standard a standard of values taking the
slings and arrows in order to protect
others right that's what being a man is
all about but we have sort of gotten rid
of that and instead we've gone with sort
of the affectation of manhoods the
affectation of manhood is I work out a
lot and I drink lots of beer and this is
what makes me a man I smoke cigars and
that's what makes me me okay what makes
you a man is whether you are willing to
protect people who are weaker than you
and whether you're willing to instill a
system of values that protects the
liberties of others who are not you
right that is what makes you a good
human being and more importantly it's
what makes you a good man in terms of
masculinity that's why it's more
important for men right and when you rip
away men's mission men tend to become
destructive but if the idea is the
masculinity now is too is too
restrictive what's so restrictive about
it well it turns out that when you
identify masculinity with the
affectation there a bunch of people who
don't like the affectation
so first the feminists came for the idea
that men should not protect women
because that was sexist and then they
came for the idea that men should not
even engage in the affectation of
manhood they should not dress like men
they should instead dress like women or
if they do dress like women that doesn't
make you less of a man
okay they've done this routine where
masculinity was reduced to the
appearance of masculinity and then that
itself was attacked so that's exactly
the case that's being made by Sarah rich
except she is attacking Shaz in
hindsight our son was gearing up to wear
a dress to school for quite some time
for months he wore dresses or his purple
and green mermaid costume on weekends
and after school then him again wearing
them to sleep in lieu of pajamas
changing out of them after breakfast
finally one morning I brought him his
clean pants and shirt and he looked at
me and said I'm already dressed he was
seated on the couch and a great cotton
sundress covered in doe-eyed unicorns
with rainbow Mane's
he slept in it and in his dreaming hours
I imagine stood at a podium giving
inspirational speeches to an audience
composed only of himself when he'd woken
up he was ready he walked a half block
to school with a bounce in his step
just proud my friends are gonna say
dresses aren't for boys he told me
casually over your shoulder
they might I agreed you can just tell
them you are comfortable with yourself
and that's all that matters
I thought of all the other things he
could tell them I began to list them but
he was off running across the blacktop I
scanned the entrance to see whether any
parents noticed us as they came and went
I hadn't expected my stomach to churn I
felt proud of him for his
self-assuredness for the way he prepared
for this quietly and at his own pace but
I worried about what judgements and
conclusions parents and teachers might
make and of course I was worried that
somebody would shame him well they
shouldn't shame him they should shame
you you're a bad parents okay I'm just
gonna put this out there you are a bad
parent you should not be allowing your
young boy who is not old enough to
figure out the ways of life because the
kid was not hit puberty yet this is not
a kid who's old enough to have figured
out masculinity and femininity for you
to have sent him to school in a dress
said it can be made fun of by all the
other kids is a nasty thing for you to
do as a parent there is something to the
idea that you should be inculcating yes
even the appearance of masculinity and
femininity in your own children
distinctions between the sexes are
important and it is you hard confusing
your child your child is not going to be
happier because your child is confused
as a general rule there are exceptions
but as a general rule being gender
confused and being confused about the
these sort of appearances of gender it
is not a worthwhile thing okay you're
pleased with his self-assuredness the
kids seven the whole self-esteem
movement the idea that you can
subjectively define the reality around
you and everybody is expected to adapt
that is not going to work out well and
now that doesn't mean the kid should be
bullied the kid should not be bullied
bullying is bad in all cases you
shouldn't bully the kids but parents
have an obligation to protect their kids
from bullying and they also have an
obligation not to confuse their kids
about basic concepts of sex and gender
the idea that that boys and girls dress
differently is true in every society in
the history of mankind
now you may say that there other
societies where boys were killed sore
boys wear skirts or whatever it is
that's not true in American society
and is true that in Scottish society men
and women do not dress the same men and
women do not trust the same because men
and women are in fact not the same and
it is important to read inculcate those
those gender differences those gender
differences are a beautiful part of life
those gender differences make your
child's less confused you're telling me
when the kid was three and put on a
dress you couldn't said you know what
sweetheart that's not really appropriate
let's go put on some boy clothes but
even that statement is apparently too
radical for the entire left and and
listen I'll get a lot of flack for
saying this obviously from the left
because the idea is that we're supposed
to pretend that all choices you make for
your child's are equivalent they are not
equivalent this cart achill continues in
the afternoon he was still wearing the
unicorn dress he skipped down the
sidewalk reporting that some kids had
protested his attire but he just he
assured them he was comfortable with
himself with that the seal was broken
most days since he's weren't addressed
from his small collection though he also
favors a light-blue guayaberas the
classic collared button-down worn by men
and boys in Cuba and the Philippines
classmates objections continue above
less frequency and conviction one day
when my husband dropped him off here at
a little girl stand up to a naysayer and
shout boys can like beautiful things too
but they can't not without someone
looking askance to embrace anything
other than feminine if you're not
biologically female causes discomfort
and confusion because throughout most of
history in most parts of the world being
a woman has been a disadvantage no that
is not right to embrace the to embrace
female dress when you are not a woman
it's not about that female hood is less
it is the idea that masculinity and
female hood are distinct okay these are
not the same thing and that when you
blow through those distinctions you are
making life worse for your child hate
contender confusion and children is a
dangerous thing it is not a good thing
and reinstalling that reinstating that I
don't know why you would want to do this
as a parent I mean I understand why she
why this person won did you convert you
signal about it in the pages of the
Atlantic so she can prove what a
wonderful person she is by giving her
child the Russo Ian Amil childhood where
the child gets to make every decision
for themselves children are not capable
of making important decisions for
themselves before you're on a
two-year-old they do not get to make
important decisions for themselves
because if they tell you if they did
they would both make stupid decisions
because little kids are stupid okay
little kids don't know anything the
whole point of civilizing young
barbarians into civilized people is to
make sure that you set some sort of
standard now is this the most important
thing in the world that you don't let
your kid dress in a dress I don't think
it's like the most important thing in
the world but I do think that it is
important to say that boys and girls are
different and to reinstitute again the
reason that it is important to
reinstitute these differences is because
biologically boys are different than
girls this has ramifications for
everything ranging from the sorts of
activities in which they engage to the
sorts of ways that they think okay these
things are ingrained and really and
reveling in the beauty of those
differences good thing it's so funny the
entire left it says multiculturalism is
wonderful right at all cultures are
created equal and we ought to celebrate
each culture for what it is says the
cultural appropriation from males to
females is totally fine and vice versa
we shouldn't celebrate the differences
between men and women we should have
litter eight the differences between men
and women well this is one of the key
distinctions in society that actually
matters the distinction between men and
women matters because boys are not the
same as girls boys must be brought up to
be gentlemen it's not that you teach
boys not to rape it's that you teach
them to affirmatively be good men and
you teach women should be good women and
being a good man is not quite the same
thing as being a good woman and then
there's a broader category of being a
good person right which encompasses some
aspects of being a good man and being a
good woman but being a good man and
being good woman two different things
that the left is pushing this this
obliteration of all distinctions that
actually matter and the goal here is of
course that once everything is done we
will all be the same we will all be
widgets that we get to form from from
scratch people are so in love with the
idea of human beings as the blank slate
that they are going to pretend that
human beings actually are a blank slate
or they're going to encourage all sorts
of activities that look more like blank
slate activities as opposed to the
biological differences that make
humanity beautiful and wonderful and
this is what the left is embracing on a
large scale and it really is disturbing
it's bad for kids okay this kid is not
going to be healthier in my opinion as a
result of his mother sending him to
school in a dress the fact is even if
the kid it happens to have gender
dysphoria eighty percent of all children
who identify as a member of the other
gender hey I understand cross-dressing
and gender dysphoria not the same thing
but eighty percent of kids who have the
most extreme form of body dysmorphia
they believe that they are a girl in a
boy's body grow out of it by the time
they are teenagers they grow out of it
over time be a parent okay it's not your
job to be your kid's friend is not your
job to enable every choice your kid
makes be a parent find a standard that
actually makes your kid's life happier
and then make society around you better
okay so meanwhile we the City of Seattle
has decided they're going to do now an
about-face on on Amazon and the head tax
I'm gonna sketch all that in just a
second first you're gonna have to go
over to daily wire calm and subscribe so
for $9.99 a month you can subscribe to
daily wire when you do you get the rest
of this show live the rest of Michael
Noel's show live the rest of the Andrew
Clavin show live and you get all of
those for just $99.99 a month or you
also can get all of that with the annual
subscription which comes along with
leftist year's hot or cold mug Ramon's
this tumbler which is just fantastic and
you get that for cheaper than the
monthly subscription also by now you've
probably heard the bed
Shapiro's show is available in Amazon
Alexa and Google homes if you have a
virtual assistant you can listen to my
podcast with a simple voice command
after we enable the skill on Alexa or
ask Google to talk to the show for more
information you can check out our pin
and Twitter and that will allow you to
do all of that plus you should subscribe
go over to iTunes go over to YouTube
subscribe and that makes make certain
that you will be updated when we have
our Sunday special so this Sunday
special is going to be with skeptic
magazine editor his name is Michael
Shermer and Michael Shermer is awesome
yeah I think you'll really enjoy him he
and I disagree about a lot of things
he's a militant atheist I of course him
a religious Jew but our discussion I
think was great and you can here's a
little bit of preview hi I'm Michael
Shermer I'm happy to be here on ben
shapiro sunday special where we'll be
talking about well pretty much every big
issue there is god free will
consciousness science and religion the
basis of morality right and wrong i mean
did we leave anything out and and and by
the way oh we answer all the questions
so you get the whole thing in an hour
you don't have to go to college you
don't have to read the bible just tuned
in that's all you need so go check that
out also our next episode of the
conversation is next week this tuesday
june 19 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m.
Pacific we will answer all of your
questions I will answer all the
questions that you send in you have
subscribed to answer to ask those
questions over daily where calm or you
can also just watch online but then you
can't actually ask the questions the
live Q&A is available on YouTube and
Facebook again for everyone to watch you
have to subscribe to ask the questions
you go over to daily wire or the
conversation page you ask questions in
the chat box and then we will answer
them for you so you know go over to
daily wire we have to sign off over at
Facebook we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so as I said left has become rather
radical and we're supposed to ignore
that because the right is also becoming
more reactionary but the less radicalism
means that they even have had to
about-face on some of their own
proposals so yeah and this is hilarious
the Seattle Times is reporting that if
you remember just a couple of weeks ago
the Seattle City Council approved if
they had tax they were going to tax
Amazon and Microsoft and all of these
other companies some huge amount 275
bucks per employee for homelessness
they're going to they were going to tax
all these major companies in the city of
Seattle less than a month later they
reversed it so in a stunning reversal
without parallel in Seattle's recent
political history according to Daniel
Beekman of the Seattle Times the City
Council voted 72 on Tuesday to repeal a
controversial head tax on large
employers like Amazon Mayor Jennings
irken plans to sign the repeal into law
that lasted for about five seconds the
move came as a business back campaign to
kill the tax prepared to submit petition
signatures this week to qualify the
referendum for the November ballot
people on both sides of the head tax
debate pack the council chambers waving
signs with the slogans tax Amazon and no
tax on jobs as the council members voted
they were drowned out by activists who
chanted housing is a human right before
the tally council member Lisa her bold
said she felt like crying but she would
side with the majority of her colleagues
because the Seattle metropolitan Chamber
of Commerce had managed to persuade the
vast majority of voters to oppose the
tax in other words they knew that when
the tax came up for a vote it was going
to lose they preemptively decided to
kill the tax and they all felt like
crying because it turns out when you
pass some of the world's stupidest
policies even the leftist voters of
Seattle can't stand it and you're going
to have to reverse yourselves and then
weep about it her boat said she lost
hope over the weekend after seeing poll
results and talking with advocates
better to retreat now rather than see
voters cancel the tax in November after
a months-long bitter struggle she said
quote this is not a winnable battle at
this time the opposition has unlimited
resources I love how the the left in
Seattle suggests that the Chamber of
Commerce has unlimited resources it's
the City of Seattle his City of Seattle
is about as left the city as there is in
the United States and yet even the city
of Seattle is gone nope sorry can't do
that you're gonna alienate all the
businesses so as the left moves further
to the left they are alienating the
center well you would assume from that
and maybe the best move for the right
would be to you know grab that Center
since the left is apparently abandoning
that Center well instead the right is
having so much fun drinking leftist
hears that some on the right have
decided in primaries that it is
worthwhile to simply go after the
candidate who is the most Trump II in FX
the the candidate who is most ensconced
in sort of the the radical language that
takes off the left which is why last
night Cory Stewart won his primary in
Virginia so Cory Stewart was running
against a guy named Nick free toss that
the campaign was really close to came
down to 2% and Cory Stewart who was
expected to win it should be said by
double digits I he'd run a very close
race before in Virginia I believe for
the governors for the governor's seat
and then he was beaten by Ed Gillespie
in in that governor's primary well now
he's won the Senate runoff and he's
gonna run against Tim Kaine he will
likely lose but Corey Stewart won and he
was he won because he was sort of the
most Trump II guy in the race now Corey
Stewart comes along with an enormous
amount of baggage that Corey Stewart has
Hobnobs with with some pretty nefarious
characters in the past he's tried to
disassociate from those characters he
went to a a sort of neo Confederate ball
he's he made one of his key issues the
upholding of Confederate monuments which
i think is a controversial issue at the
very least
Corey Stewart is he's a political animal
for sure and he's again likely to lose
to in in the race to Tim Kaine but it
seems like the right in its desire for a
reactionary anti-establishment politics
is embracing candidates who may not be
the strongest candidates in the world
the same thing holds true in South
Carolina last night so Mark Sanford lost
his congressional primary last night
he's in almost 5 - a member of the House
of Representatives and he lost his
primary election to a political newcomer
State Representative Katy Arrington by a
fifty point five percent is forty six
point five percent margin and Arrington
was a Romney and Rubio supporter in in
the primaries she ended up supporting
Trump and said she would do so in the
house Sanford was a trump supporter in
the 2016 election the media's the media
is sort of take on this is that Sanford
was too anti Trump to win I don't think
that's actually true I think what
happened is the tan four ran a really
lackluster campaign his own in his own
district but the impact is going to be
that that Arrington is more militant in
her approach Sanford is a lot less
militant and also he said some pretty
abrasive things about President Trump in
the past so what does this mean for
Republican primary voters what does this
mean for the Republican Party in general
well it means that I understand why
there's caution on the part of
Republican legislators going up against
President Trump the fact is that you
cannot be fully anti Trump and win in
there
publican party right now end of story
you cannot be fully anti-trump in the
Republican Party as a legislator and win
and that makes a certain amount of sense
and in the sense that President Trump is
in fact the President of the United
States but it does mean cutting off your
nose to spite your face because the fact
is that mark Sanford was voting 90
percent of the time with President Trump
including on some of his biggest
priorities Katy Arrington is a bigger
government proponent and she campaigned
against marks an from being too small
government which suggests that if you
are voting for a candidate based on
their support level for president
Trump's language rather than president
Trump's agenda or if you're voting for a
Republican candidate based on how much
they like Trump not how much they like
limited government that should be a sign
that you're doing something wrong Kay
that's not actually a really good thing
I think okay in just a second I want to
talk about immigration and AT&T Time
Warner but the let's you know let's get
to this immigration stories this is an
amazing story there there's a lot of
talk these days about President Trump
being too harsh on immigration this has
been specifically said about separating
families at the border as I have made
clear in the past the law of the land
requires that families be separated at
the border when there is an illegal
immigrant who brings a child across the
border and you want to arrest the
illegal immigrant the Left solution is
don't arrest the illegal immigrant which
is no solution at all
illegal immigration continues to be a
threat to certain areas of the country I
don't think that illegal immigrants are
generally coming across to commit crimes
I don't think the illegal immigrants are
bad people I know too many illegal
immigrants to believe that but I do
believe that any country that is worth
its salt has to enforce its border and
it is also true that we cannot affect
the people who are coming through
illegally we just can't and the latest
case in point of this is a situation at
a high school in an apparently Maryland
where ms-13 is now recruiting people
this morning the Washington Post ok this
is not a right-wing source the boys had
once been friends before ms-13 began
recruiting one of them now as other
students streamed to class one April
morning at William Wirt Middle School in
Riverdale Maryland this middle schoolers
cousin like 11 or 12 the two teens
squared off in the third story bathroom
I'll fight captured by another student
on his cell phone the ms-13 recruit
threw a punch at his former friends head
his opponent ducked and tackled the 15
year old their sneakers squealing as
they tumbled to the green tile floor I
like that someone shouted off-camera is
the recruit tried to cover his head that
looks like it hurt someone wrote under
the video which was uploaded to
Instagram
gang-related fights are now a near daily
occurrence at work when a small group of
suspected ms-13 members of the
overwhelmingly Hispanic school
Prince George's County throw gang signs
sell drugs draw gang graffiti and
aggressively recruit students recently
arrived from Central America according
to more than two dozen teachers parents
and students most of those interviewed
asked not to be identified for fear of
losing their jobs or being targeted by
ms-13 now remember when President form
called ms-13 II animals amend many
people on the Left we're very upset
about all this this is a serious problem
okay it's a real problem when ms-13 is
recruiting in junior High's that's scary
stuff although administrators deny Ward
has a gang problem the situation inside
the aging overcrowded building has left
some teachers so afraid they refused to
be alone with their students many said
they had repeatedly reported incidents
involving suspected gang members to
administrators only to be ignored claims
supported by documents obtained by The
Washington Post teachers feel threatened
but aren't backed up students feel
threatened but aren't protected one
educator said the school is a ticking
time bomb
the gangs President worked comes at a
time when the Trump administration has
declared war on ms-13 and communities
throughout the country are confronting a
surge in ms-13 related violence this is
why I'm not going to get on Attorney
General Jeff Sessions for being harsh on
immigration I don't think that he is
wrong about his perspective on
immigration so Jeff Sessions has gotten
into controversial territory recently
because he released a 31 page decision
narrowing the grounds for asylum for
victims of private crime so the asylum
law is that if you are a victim of a
government that if you are coming to the
United States because you're a political
dissident basically that we are more
likely to grant you Asylum but we had
broadened that out to include people who
for example we're victims of domestic
abuse he live in Guatemala and your
husband beats you and now we have to
take you in for asylum Jeff Sessions had
said this is not what the law is for and
here is what he here's what he had to
say about it asylum was never meant to
alleviate all problems even all serious
problems that people face every day all
over the world so today I'm exercising
the responsibility given to me under the
I na and I will be issuing a decision
that restores sound principles of asylum
and long standing principles of
immigration law okay this makes some
sense I mean people are ripping on him
but this makes a fair bit of sense
considering the fact that if you're a
victim of domestic violence that should
not be your entry ticket to the United
States the question really is whether
the government is failing to protect you
from domestic violence for example or
whether the government is up
the rights of the domestic violator you
know that sort of stuff is sort of a
different story but if the goal here is
that anyone who has ever suffered in the
world can come into the United States I
think that that's a mistake now that
doesn't mean that we shouldn't find ways
to help them that private charities
particularly shouldn't find ways to help
these people escape from domestic
violence situations and there are
private charities that do help this to
happen
but just because the United States is a
great place and there are a lot of
people suffering doesn't mean that it's
the responsibility of the United States
to take people in without vetting them
or determining whether they're going to
be an addition to the United States
unvetted immigration is a problem it is
a problem and it's a problem that has to
be dealt with seriously without all the
sloganeering that seems to accompany all
of this okay so it's time for a couple
of things that I like and then a couple
of things that I hate so a couple of
things that I like you gotta love the
fact that alec baldwin still thinks that
he is a relevant player on the American
political scene so Alec Baldwin is of
the weird opinion that if he ran for
president he would be President Trump
Iran I would win you would I would
absolutely when I ran for president I
would win hands down I would be cause
you would be the funniest most exciting
why do you praise II can't okay that is
not true okay if Alec Baldwin runs he
will not win Alec Baldwin barely has the
support of a few people on the Left let
alone anybody on the right he's deeply
off-putting but if everybody but how the
left wants to turn if they if the
Democrats want to turn to a celebrity
candidate because they think they need a
celebrity to be Trump more power to them
enjoy yourselves now keep campaigning on
Bernie and Alec Baldwin keep doing it
guys I'm I really am appreciative okay
other things that I like so there's a
ruling that a lot of people don't like
they came down from a district court the
Trump administration had been
challenging the ability of AT&T and Time
Warner to merge there's no reason to
challenge this this merger okay they're
legitimately no reason so I am very much
a advocate of free market capitalism and
that means that I'm generally anti
antitrust laws so antitrust laws the
idea that you have to break up companies
when they get too large the only time
there's such a thing as a true monopoly
is when there is a company that owns 100
percent market share in a particular
industry and then can raise the prices
to a sky-high level that's a true
monopoly AT&T Time Warner would not be a
true monopoly in terms of market value
of new media amazon.com is now valued at
817 billion dollars AT&T Time Warner
would be valued at 282 billion dollars
so it's not that they
control a hundred percent of the market
they don't control ten percent of the
market
okay Verizon is worth two hundred and
three billion Netflix is worth one
hundred and fifty seven billion Disney
is worth one hundred fifty five billion
and what you're gonna start seeing is
some of these companies consolidate to
fight AT&T time order now the people who
are objecting are saying well the reason
AT&T in is trying to buy time order is
they're trying to buy their
entertainment content and then in in
accordance with the new net neutrality
rules which have been gotten rid of now
AT&T is going to be able to use time
warner entertainment as sort of their
base of operations they're going to use
and privilege time warner entertainment
and put it on their own their own
distribution mechanisms and privilege
that content okay fine so so what
so then Verizon partners and Netflix or
Verizon partners of Disney or Verizon
partners of Fox or something that's fine
this is what competition does if they
really want to charge me more for non
Time Warner content and there's another
company offering me a better deal then I
will go to that other company when the
fact is we are now getting more
entertainment for cheaper than ever in
human history I mean if you go to
Netflix or Amazon I subscribe to both
the amounts of entertaining that is
available at the touch of a button is
just astounding it's just astounding and
the fact is all these cable companies
are gonna die anyway because people are
cutting the cord at incredibly rapid
rates so what's gonna happen then well
you're gonna need a new way to make
revenue and one of the ways to make
revenue is to own the entertainment
producing fora that are actually making
the entertainment and then you
distribute them online I don't see a
huge problem with that the truth is that
President Trump has demonstrated that
he's not a big fan of the folks over at
I'm or doesn't like CNN but that has
nothing to do with this particular
merger and as a free-market capitalist I
think that the merger is absolutely fine
okay time for some things that I hate
already so it now turns out that Sarah
Huckabee Sanders called Dennis Rodman
with a message of thanks from President
Trump for his involvement in the
negotiations in North Korea this is
utterly unnecessary Dennis Rodman is a
crazy person and I understand is its do
any real harm no is it stupid yes
you know I criticized the president for
his association with Kim Kardashian
Dennis Rodman is eight times as crazy as
Kim Kardashian now if the idea is that
Dennis Rodman got Kim to the table how
about this how about we we say
congratulations to one another once can
actually make some concessions can wait
for that otherwise you end up with tape
like this Sarah Huckabee Sanders on the
phone congratulating Dennis Rodman in an
alternative universe where Biff
eventually actually went back to 1955
and actually bet on the sports book here
is Dennis Rodman being congratulated by
the White House okay so there's Dennis
Rodman being congratulated by the White
House we now live in the most stupid
timeline I think it is fair to say these
are listen can you use people like
Dennis Rodman for diplomacy I suppose
you can but yeah I just I gotta say I
sort of object to the degradation of the
White House the point where they're
calling Dennis Rodman illegitimate crazy
person to talk about his relationship
with Kim Jong hoon maybe it's practical
I'm open to arguments that I'm wrong on
this but it's it you know what I think
they it's not a thing I hate as much as
the thing that I'm uncomfortable with
how about how's that okay so we will be
back here tomorrow with all the latest
news we'll be broadcasting from Dallas
we'll see you then I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018